we were just talking about trust there
of course a big part of the uk's future
outside of the eu will be
striking trade deals agreements with
other countries
we've just gone back on a deal that we
struck
less than a year ago why should anyone
trust us
what we're doing sophie is making sure
that
if the joint committee negotiations
about the protocol
fail and there's still a way to go when
it comes to that
we have an insurance policy here in the
uk
to make sure that uh any uh
conflicts any disagreements are not
uh against the interests of the internal
market of the united kingdom the
sovereignty
of our own country this isn't something
that we do lightly this isn't something
that we actually want to have to
use this is something that a responsible
government does
in order to prepare for the worst but
can i reiterate
our steely determination to get a deal
not just the free trade deal
but the agreement on the protocol
to make sure that it works in the
interests of the republic
of ireland in the interests of the
united kingdom
and most importantly in the interests of
all the peoples of northern ireland
what i'm trying to get my head around is
why you need an insurance policy
for your own insurance policy because
if the deal is so bad why did boris
johnson come on this show and describe
it as fantastic why did he go into an
election campaign with it front and
center
of that campaign was he lying when he
said it was a good deal or did you just
not understand
it well sophie i caught most of what you
said there
uh due to passing traffic but i think
what you said is why are we
putting an insurance policy on an
insurance a backstop my question
my question i'll repeat the question
boris johnson said
that the withdrawal agreement was a
fantastic deal he told me that he went
into an election campaign
uh using on that deal so when he's now
saying that it's a bad deal that you
need an insurance policy against it was
he lying when he said the withdrawal
agreement was a good deal
or did he just not understand it
no what we're doing is preparing for
the eventuality which we hope will not
come to pass of a failure by the
joint committee that was set up under
the protocol to
to come to an agreement as to how to
operate it you know we're going to
exhaust
all those means in order to make sure
that the protocol works there are
mechanisms that the joint committee can
invoke that we will
follow through with but if that fails if
we are left
by the end of the year with an
unresolved position
it's our obligation to do something to
make sure that we are
prepared you know we could have just
pretended that all was going to be well
avoided the issue kicked the can down
the road as
perhaps we used to do but that would
have been an irresponsible approach we
need to be upfront
about the potential problem that could
arise we're doing that
and that's why those clauses have been
included
i mean we're talking here about joint
committees protocols mechanisms but
really
it strikes me that what's happened is
actually very simple the government's
trying to override a deal that it struck
less than a year ago now as lord
chancellor you took an oath
to protect the rule of law and yet this
week the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis told the house of commons
that the government is
intending to break or the internet
internal market bill
does break international law in a very
specific
and limited way are you going to resign
it's not a question about me or my
position the whole government
is actually committed to the rule of law
uh i
as lord chancellor of course speak more
chiefly for the government
on those general issues and i can assure
you that what we are doing is in
accordance with i think
actually the most honorable traditions
of the british state which is to
alert everyone to the possibility of a
problem
to actually legislate prepare ourselves
domestically for that
but to make the point that we're not at
that stage yet
and we don't have to be if all parties
come together
and work with a will to get these
provisions agreed
then we won't need these clauses at all
that's the government's sincere
wish we are a hundred percent committed
to these negotiations
we're going to press on with them until
at the end
but at the same time we have to be
upfront and honest
that there could be a conflict and can i
say this sophie if there is
a conflict between domestic and
international law
as a government we will seek to resolve
that conflict as quickly as possible
as we have done in other instances where
our domestic law
has come into conflict or
dislocation with international law
obligations
but the conflict is there because of a
deal that you negotiated
that you negotiated and told us all was
fantastic
and i just want to go back to what
brandon lewis said because he said that
the internal market bill does
break international law in a very
specific and limited way
you took an oath to uphold the rule of
law
so if the government breaks the law will
you resign
if we get to the stage where we have a
conflict of laws it is the duty of the
government
to seek to resolve that this isn't an
unprecedented situation
the circumstance within circumstances
within which
we are now find ourselves are of course
unprecedented
but no government has ever had to face
the job of disentangling britain's
relationship
with the eu this is totally new ground i
think it's
up to us all in government to plot a way
through this
that make sure that if conflicts arise
if differences arise if there is a
dislocation
then we should seek to resolve that but
make no mistake
we are absolutely committed to getting
the joint committee
negotiations resolved and that we hope
that these provisions will never ever
have to be used
that's my belief and that's the belief
of the government i know that you want
the you know provisions to never have to
be used but that's a little bit like
saying oh yeah we bought a balaclava
from the crowbar but we don't intend
we really hope we don't have to rob a
house with them it's not that reassuring
is it
well look i i think analogies with the
criminal law are wholly
misplaced what we're talking about here
is intricate international law
arrangements i
i heard my friend and colleague the
irish justice minister set out her
concerns
we take them extremely seriously as we
do the peace process i can reassure
the irish government i reassure all
friends in europe that
all we are seeking to do is to prepare
the drone domestically
if things are not resolved that is a
responsible course of action
we could have pretended that all was
going to be well and just avoided the
problem
and then come into infraction and
collision with europe
i think that would have been dishonest
frankly this is a much more direct
approach
yes it sets up some difficult
dichotomies
but i believe that with a will we won't
ever get
to that situation i just wonder
you know it's hard to escape the feeling
that actually boris johnson is
pretty comfortable with the idea of not
getting a trade deal you know he's
tearing up his own withdrawal agreement
to give
the government more flexibility if there
isn't a trade deal
he must have known the impact that this
explosive bill would have
on the negotiations we've heard the eu's
concerns
do you think the prime minister really
wants a deal
absolutely he wanted a deal last year
we i believed him i was right in my
belief
i know and believe that he wants a deal
this year
we as a government are working flat out
to get that deal the free trade deal
and also to resolve the protocol issues
that's our will
that's the collective will of the
british government we know it's in our
national interest
to get a good deal and that's what we're
all committed to doing
you of course voted to remain and you
say you believe the prime minister that
he wants a deal
do you have a worry of being played
do i worry about what sorry sophie do
you ever worry that you're being played
i've been in politics and i'm old for a
long time and i'm old enough and ugly
enough
to know when i'm being played i can tell
you the prime minister knows my strong
views
about the need to work positively with
our european neighbors
we as a government want a deal we are
negotiating hard to get that deal
our will is absolutely settled and
united
and we're going to get there okay and
just quickly
are you confident you've got the numbers
to get this bill through the house of
commons and the house of lords next week
well this is the next point because
parliament is going to be playing its
full part
in the debates to come about this
important issue
that's a vital part of our democracy
it's an expression of parliamentary
sovereignty
which frankly the brexit debate has been
all about i'm looking forward to carry
on engaging with
colleagues in both houses to listen to
their concerns
i believe that this bill should get
through it must get through
it's brexit critical there are many
measures in it that are vitally
important
for the 31st of december and i very much
hope that it will
command the support of both houses in
the debates to come
now i'm keen to talk about coronavares
covered 19 something of course that
all of us are very worried about we
heard from a professor peter openshaw
earlier in the program who said the
numbers are worrying we might just have
days to try and get a grip of this
can you rule out another national
lockdown
well as the prime minister said going to
a national lockdown would indeed be
a nuclear option i i think that
here in autumn 2020 knowing much more as
we do know about the nature of
covid but still without a vaccine
we have to take a range of measures
which of course include enhanced testing
localized measures and indeed the rule
of six coming in
tomorrow i think it i think the british
public now
know that by taking a combination of
different measures
we can get through this period you know
this is like a
a half marathon you know normally this
time of the year sophie i'm running half
marathons
and you get to a point in the race where
the gradient starts to go up
it feels really tough you have to dig in
remember that the finishing line is
there
and just concentrate on doing the job
and all of us you know
government members of the public have a
collective
will to get through this to save lives
and to ultimately beat this virus and i
think the
combination of measures that we now have
are the right way to minimize the threat
that we face
i wish i could say that at this time i
was usually running half marathons but
that would definitely be a lie
you're talking about a range of measures
do you think the government could be
looking at curfews
look i think that as you've seen we've
been very
prepared to move quickly where necessary
and where the evidence
points us i think that there is an issue
about social occasions and social events
and
particularly young people perhaps
getting together enjoying themselves
sometimes a bit too much and forgetting
the importance
of the rules uh i think it would be idle
of me
to speculate as to what measures we
might have to bring in
as we approach the winter i do think
that what we're doing now
is you know being clear about
prioritizing
schools colleges and the economy i'm
making the point that while social
occasions are important and of course
family social care
occasions are particularly important
they do take and they must take second
place
to those priorities and i think people
understand that they
want to support that and with the good
sense of the british people
i think we can uh get the balance right
one of one of the ways you're trying to
restrict those social interactions of
course is the rule of six i've already
mentioned it that's coming in
from tomorrow the fact that you can't
meet up with more than six
people at a time is it okay to break
that rule in a specific and limited way
i like the link that you make there
sophie
what we are seeking to do via
enforcement of the rule of six is to
encourage people to get it right to
advise them
and to enforce where the is particularly
demanding the police are well used now
to using their judgment
in every situation that is presented to
them
you know we don't want to have to resort
to enforcement proceedings but we will
do
if we see egregious breaches and of
course the fines
can be quite significant particularly
for those who repeat
the infringements let's remember why
we're doing this we're doing this
actually to protect each other
and to save lives and those basic
messages
were important back in the spring
they've been important through the
summer
and they're even more important now i am
you know trying to make a bit of a
genuine point here though because if the
government says
it's okay to break the law in a specific
and limited way
why is it not okay for the rest of us to
do that
well going back to the issue we talked
about we're talking about
a difference between international law
and domestic law
on a political scale it's a world away
i would suggest from issues of
enforcement
of the law and regulations on a
day-to-day
basis this government is absolutely
committed
to the rule of law we want to make sure
that within our united kingdom
we have a single internal market that
works for everybody
and that because of brexit we have the
sovereign
power to make decisions here at home and
that of course includes
the decisions that are made in england
on covid in wales
in scotland and in northern ireland now
we're running out of time but there's
one more question i want to ask you on
corey nevaris before asking about your
sentencing reforms and that is a
campaign that's on the front of the men
on sunday today
to try and allow partners to be present
when a woman is giving birth and often
of course you know you're thinking about
women going to
scan appointments where they might hear
very difficult news
without anyone with them going through
the experience of a miscarriage when it
might be really important to have
someone with you
to those difficult hospital and doctor's
appointments
is it not time to relax the rules and
allow people going through pregnancy and
childbirth
to have their support network with them
well so if you make a really powerful
point in all of us who have been through
that process
with our husbands wives and partners
know
how vital it is to have that emotional
support when they're pretty big life
events
happen and all can often happen so
suddenly and without
warning i think it's vital that all
local hospital
trusts and local health bodies who have
the responsibility for administering
the rules in their particular area
really lean into this issue i know a lot
of
trusts are already opened up their rules
to allow
partners and families to be with people
who are going through this i think
that's absolutely right
i know there are some who have yet to do
that i think my colleague nadine doris
the health minister
has eloquently made the case for
more uh consistency when it comes to
those decisions
i would like to see more trusts uh
get that balance right to allow loved
ones and particularly
when difficult and tough news has to be
delivered
and emotional support is uh absolutely
vital
yeah and you're right that you of course
like difficult and tough news you don't
always know when
it is going to uh come and just finally
secretary you've got an announcement on
sentencing this morning what is it that
you're trying to do
well today we've been talking about the
need to protect the public
and i want to take measures to deal with
very serious
offenders who have committed the most
grave crimes
such as murder and often mass murder to
make sure that
the sentence terms that they serve
fit the seriousness of the crime it's up
to ministers
to help set those starting points for
the judges then
to apply and i'm going to be reforming
the law further
to end the situation where just because
you might be under 21
the law bars the possibility of a
whole life order that is somebody
serving all their term
in prison i think it's right to give
judges that
discretion and later in the week i'll be
announcing more measures in a sentencing
white paper
that will uh finally give the country a
sense of what
i have worked on for the last 30 years
as a professional barrister and as a
part-time judge
but i think that sentencing can be
better can be
smarter and can be more balanced
genuinely in the interests
of public protection and also
rehabilitation
wherever appropriate